the german army looks like it's fully
equipped and ready for battle in this
recruitment video but a parliamentary
report suggests soldiers are lacking
heavy equipment body armor backpacks and
even warm underwear we don't have enough
tanks we don't have enough vessels we
don't have enough planes to be able to
even secure their own country
not even to support
our friends in securing
europe
at the last nato summit in madrid
chancellor olaf scholl said germany can
fulfill the requirements to defend the
alliance from what it describes as a
direct threat from russia
nato wants to expand its high readiness
forces from 40 000 to three hundred
thousand
the saunders from 900 million
the special fund of 100 billion euros
for investment in the armed forces is a
very important signal that we are facing
up to the challenges of the new security
situation
it's a lot of money but it's money the
armed forces needs to make up for what
we've neglected for years
as part of the 102 billion dollars
package germany is planning to buy f-35
fighter jets and related equipment for
8.4 billion dollars from the u.s but the
head of the armed forces reservists say
the number of troops should be doubled
to 350 000 as well so to build up the
structures again to have a new focus on
territorial defense and host nation
support that needs already time to build
up the structures we say more than five
years to have these five homeland
regiments so then we have the structure
to speed up the process patrick
sandsberg argues conscription needs to
be reinstated it's been called the
turning point in history decades after
the defeat of nazi germany and the end
of the cold war germany is gearing up to
become a military power again and while
a majority in parliament has supported
the expansion there are also those who
warn against growing militarism
critics point out germany is already the
world's 7th largest military spender
with a defense budget increasing more
than 55 percent in the past eight years
they say the problem is efficiency not
money the capacities for a conventional
war in
the european nato member states doubles
that of russia so there's already
deterrence
and so like this kind of arm spending is
not gonna gonna lead to a more peaceful
world on the contrary it's gonna
escalate a global arms race
despite these warnings germany says it's
committed to being an important nato
partner in the heart of europe that
other nations can rely on staff fasten
al jazeera berlin